I'm Kimberley Harvey.
I'm a dance artist, choreographer and teacher.
I have my own company, Subtle Kraft Co.,
I'm a freelance artist and I also work for
Candoco Dance Company as a Candoco artist.
For all of the work that I do,
whether as a choreographer or as a teacher,
one of the key things for me
is always the relationship,
whether to the space, to other people
or to myself.
So, that runs through everything,
and then, on the top of that,
over the past couple of years,
I've been gathering research
around the use of holding
based on my own and also with other artists.
And so this idea of holding spaces
in different ways,
and I'm drawn to spaces that hold me,
so, I will often choose to put myself
in corners
or behind pillars or in alcoves
where there is a kind of
a sense of being held by the space.
I have two works
that really stand out for me.
One is a solo that I made most recently
called "Inky Matter"
and where basically I'm fascinated by letters,
particularly handwritten ones,
and for ages I thought that it was only me.
And then I realised that I had lots of letters
in me that I've never written or that I've never sent,
and then the more I talked to people,
the more I realised that they did as well.
And also, for me, I placed the letters
in very particular parts of my body,
so that, as a dancer,
was a perfect starting point.
And then the other one is a film
I made a few years ago,
which is called "On the Tip of my Tongue",
which I made with a friend
and a colleague of mine,
and the reason I love it
is because it came from me
going to Andrew Graham,
who is the other performer,
and saying:
"We've known each other for years
but I've never actually directed with you.
I love what you do as a dancer
and as an artist. I want to work
with you and I want to make a dance film."
And I said "Would you be up for it?"
and he said “Yes”.
And from there we then created the brief
of the film together.
And it was what is our language
as a duet,
because he is almost 6 foot
(183cm)
and I'm definitely not 6 foot,
and I'm out of the chair for part of it as well,
so we did some in the chair
and some out of the chair,
and because of the relationship
that we have,
it's also one of trust,
I was able to do things with him
in a very short space of time.
I love that my job enables me
to play and to communicate
in a variety of ways, as a teacher,
as a choreographer and as a performer.
And I think as adults particularly,
we lose the ability to play.
We get told that we are too old to play
or that we should be serious now
because we are adults.
In the dance environment you see
a micro world
which is really beautiful and things
happen and are being made
in a creative setting
that you kind of wish you could
diffuse to everybody,
because we are not frightened of proximity,
we are less fearful of touch
and we are less fearful of communicating
in a variety of diverse ways.
There's an openness in the creative space
which there isn't in the wider world.